oh snap you leave those honor you can
take them off it's okay that hey
everybody
I finally got listened back on yes so we
have now seen after actually
successfully avoiding spoilers for a
week we've now seen endgame yes we have
we're gonna talk about it we will we
will alert you when we're gonna get into
flat-out spoiler territory but if you
want to do what we did which was to go
into the movie with as little even sense
it like I haven't even watched full
reviews then you know maybe don't watch
this at all but like okay just broad
impression um I really liked it I
thought it was like suitable ending to
this whole saga and story I really liked
how they tied some things up um I think
I can say that rocket was snarky without
that you brought some levity to it um
yeah yeah I think that yeah there are
certain characters I wanted to see a
little more of that were a lot alive
after the snap yeah and they I think
they could have incorporated more but
all in all I was pretty happy it we did
not go to the bathroom once yes we were
super impressed with there's a three
hour plus movie neither of us got to go
to the bathroom that was yeah like I'm
not gonna say that I love this movie as
much as I love other Marvel movies but
this is an impressive achievement
because first of all it is a three hour
plus movie and I feel that it does not I
was never bored and like yes
impress it for me because I'm easily
distractible and like
this my feet are also you know this
might be a Tod comparison but it struck
me almost more like marathoning like the
last three episodes of a TV show you're
like super intense yeah yeah in that it
doesn't do the thing that most long
movies do which is to tell a story that
could probably be told in a shorter
amount of time but just take a long time
to do it this was actually a pretty
brisk story I mean they took moments to
pause but it was a pretty brisk story
and it was always moving forward it just
had a lot to do and so it felt way more
justified in its runtime than most
things that creep up over two and a half
hours and I think without spoiling we
can say there it was definitely had some
nice homage moments to oh yeah it was it
was properly a celebration of the entire
franchise up until this point and I
think that if you have if you're trying
to avoid any even possible degree of
spoilers that's that's your cue to like
head out if you like the MCU I don't see
how you how you can't like get something
out of this probably a lot of some
things so we'll huh God you know what
heck with it we're just gonna talk
spoilers from now on we're not gonna
we're not gonna bother censoring so
there's gets killed quickly which I was
not expecting I was like well okay
because I thought most of it would be
like my impression my thought was that
somehow they would be trying to take
like a stone off at a time or somehow
destroy it remotely I didn't quite know
what was going on
I thought that would be most of the
movie this was not at all what I was
expecting and I I like that yeah I mean
that that's the thing as this thing went
along like I didn't have specific
expectations of what I wanted it to be
but I still like every major plot turn
and I'm like okay I would not have
called them doing that and actually what
I like about Thanos getting killed at
the front end and then obviously showing
up again later for the climax because of
timing
but yeah what I like about that initial
thing is that not only does he get taken
off the burner like what do we do now
that he destroyed the gauntlet so he
destroyed their means of ever being able
to fix it and it really just leave me
going oh crap
what what did he know what does anybody
do now like what aah
and I do like that they even kind of
took the breath to show people trying to
move forward with their lives and not
like very obviously not having a honest
success in doing yeah yeah yeah you
could tell that like Natasha oh man this
broke her oh yeah and and Captain
America and obviously claim I mean that
was the beginning was like
heart-wrenching like where he's just
looking around and it's like what where
is everyone
cuz it is his whole family yeah cuz I
was like oh they'll probably I mean he
has a big family like they'll probably
leave him with someone and I'm like oh
no no he had the uh he had the world's
worst jackpot yeah yes boilers Oh about
from now on well I mean I did already
say okay um so like and there were there
were lots of little moments that I liked
I liked I liked cap with that little
like sort of support meeting thing with
the guy talking about going on a date
then he mentions this with another guy
which I thought was like oh that's nice
that that's just there I mean like this
it's a nobody it's not like Oh character
I was like they had a gay one scene day
player but it was still nice it was a
nice moment and I appreciated it
regardless I'm not gonna Pat them on the
back too hard for it but like oh thank
you so boy where do we even go from they
they put Thor through the ringer didn't
they
oh okay so that was one of this this was
one of your few complaints I thought and
that was actually something that hadn't
been spoiled for me
a little bit I didn't know it was
necessarily Thor but we had a friend
that was like they have a person and a
fat suit and I was like really that's
not like in the 1990s like why do we
have someone in that and I was like not
quite sure what they meant cuz again
didn't want spoilers so didn't look into
it and I was like they didn't need to go
that far no no we had this conversations
that what I will say as far as fat suits
go that was not in a particularly
offensive fat suit they didn't like have
this whole thing up and like to this
bulbous chin and a flaw they didn't do
that so any fat suit is I will I'll
actually agree with that but I'm just
saying like on the scale of you already
did something wrong how long did you do
it I'm putting it on the lower end of
that but in any case what I would say
and we had this conversation last night
like I I think is fully justified that
Thor basically gives up and kind of lets
himself go but I think all they had to
do was have Chris Hemsworth stop working
out for three months and lose his
definition that would have been enough
or done some kind of like you know CGI
kind of trick yeah they they didn't they
didn't need to have the gym jiggling
about and have him shirtless for his
entire first scene yeah they could put
more crud in his hair like that would
have worked and give him the same
impression more uh more cheeto dust yeah
like stuff yeah um I did like the Big
Lebowski comment was great yeah you
whispered it to me like three seconds
before Tony made that comment called him
Lebowski somebody get that man a White
Russian yeah yeah no that that was good
stuff
you mentioned rocket I know that you you
found his his snark to be oh it was
great a very necessary balm to the
proceedings at times and Scott was a
little too dumb at points like poking
him and being like hey puppy
go into space that's not dumb but Scott
is so far out of his league on this one
which I actually did think at for a
moment like when I saw the trailers when
they kept showing ant-man I'm like he's
gonna be important to this and like his
he's like the quantum realm you're gonna
be important to it so when they brought
him back I'm like there's something
going on here this is where they're
gonna find their way yeah it's all thing
so I actually want to talk about the
time-travel mechanics of this cuz I
found them really fascinating for a
couple of weeks so they basically did
two things one of which I've never seen
done in fiction actually neither of
which I've ever seen done in fiction
that I can think of it probably probably
have been but so generally speaking and
this gets addressed in the movie
repeatedly where people like well this
is how time travel works cuz of this
movie in this movie in this movie in
this movie and then and they're like
well no those are movies are you see
Back to the Future why to us but what
it's always been before is either go
back to the past change it and it
changes you when you come back to the
present everything's changed or go back
to the past and nothing changes because
the past already happened with you being
part of it what this does is what it
says is when you go back you can do
whatever you want but it will not affect
you and your timeline because even
though you've gone back to a past you
are still in your own personal timeline
present and you cannot affect your own
personal timeline present because you
can't go back to your own personal
timeline past and when you try it
creates a divergent alternate timeline
now the alternate timeline I've seen
done before but was different here is
they said well no you create an
alternate timeline you don't get to be
on that alternate timeline you're still
on the one you've always been on
oh this how can they have this like how
can Thor have take his hammer from that
time line well that was what the ancient
one was explaining to Bruce with what
the time is and it's why they had to
send the the stones back to the same
point that they were taken to remove the
divergent time line but what she was
explaining was you create a divergent
time line that will now do its own thing
that's not your time line you don't get
to exist on that but you've created one
so the combination of those two created
a situation where they get to have all
the fun of time travel of going back and
enter in overlapping with past movies
and bringing back so many characters who
we haven't seen in ages either because
they're dead or the story has had no use
of them but not completely destroy the
continuity of the franchise no because
if they'd done that if they just come
literally rewritten it it would have
kind of taken the fun out of the old
movies you would have gone back and go
well this isn't even the case anymore
but now it still is mm-hmm because
they're not trying to uh they're not
trying to stop fantasy for he does it
they're trying to get the resources to
fix it after the fact and it's like it
kind of it kind of made my head spin but
like in a good way and I really thought
that was clever yeah I mean there are
some things where I was like wait wait
okay yeah all right okay I guess this
works but now that you've explained it I
I think I understand it a little more
javi I captain
honestly I could have gone for one more
scene of explanation but I kinda like
technobabble
if it if there's a logic to it so your
thing and you so I got bored like timing
wine I do I don't back well I obviously
seen Back to the Future all of them but
like I haven't seen a lot of time travel
i watch enough time i watch enough time
travel things to distinguish between a
time travel movie in a time loop movie
so that that should tell you most people
though would classify say twelve Monkeys
a time travel I file that under time
loop and all those other stuff anyway
anyways yes I'm getting distracted and
it's a lot of like man like Sorrows this
was heavy
I guess so yeah okay so some of the
characters who we got to see who we
haven't seen in a while or who are dead
we got we got some additional bits of
Loki yes yes thanks bye made so many of
my friends happy yeah cuz of course he
did
cuz he's Loki yeah it was very nice to
see agent Carter back yes aye aye again
I'm not a big fan of a lot of the Marvel
romances but the two they had in here
are two I really the two I like
why being Peggy Ann and Steve and Tony
and pepper yeah Tony and pepper I can
see yeah yeah yeah I mean those are the
ones that work really well and we got
Gamora back kind of but it's a Gamora
from earlier in time so she has not
followed him for quill yet which means
she kneed him in the balls which
somebody needed to knee him in the balls
yeah I was okay I was very angry with
him after the last movie because he kind
of boarded their plan with his emotions
and it's a good thing the movie came out
a year later because you basically
needed a year to calm down like alright
you can come back and the theme you know
when we first see him it's him dancing
around from the first movie and I'm like
yeah okay I kind of I guess I miss you a
little bit quill but oh I like that they
brought back even like characters who I
never expect to see bag so like when
they're giving the the I guess it was
the scepter uh-huh to shield aegis and
I'm like wait a minute those are the
guys who are actually hydrate and donees
like oh these guys are shield Oh
actually they're Hydra but we didn't
know that yet and then they they
basically they start to recreate the the
the scene the set up for the elevator
fight in Winter Soldier except Steve cuz
he knows just these four leans towards
one of them goes hail Hydra and then
they instantly trust him
oh god I loved that I thought that was
genius
they got Robert Redford back for a scene
like props yeah um the most touching to
me was Rene Russo yes honestly if we had
to have someone back I was much rather
have her back and like be a center focus
then Jane Foster who we so briefly but
like I want somebody to figure out if
they used old footage and like maybe cut
scenes an alternate tapes cuz I don't
think they actually brought her back on
set I'm gonna make a leap yeah I'm gonna
make a leap I don't know but I was I was
very glad to see her back ya know
Thor's mom was that was a great scene
that was a really touching and actually
I like what they've done with Thor's
character trajectory where they where
his basically the conversation with his
mother unburdened him from the
responsibilities of but this is your
destiny this is what you're supposed to
do and kind of frees him just to figure
out what he wants to do which is net
because you know for all the ups and
downs of the franchise Thor has never
been unburdened from responsibilities
he's definitely taken I mean it's been a
awful time for him even as fun as
Ragnarok was it was like it was like
that was still wrong homeland like and
you've lost your sister and your dad and
it's rough stuff well it also seems like
they set him up to be in guardians of
the galaxy 3 which I board for that yeah
totally cool it cuz like I'm not sure
you can build a movie around Thor again
because if is if his Arquette if his
personal story at this point is just
bumming around and figuring out what he
wants to do I'm not sure you get them
they can build those shorts around him
there you go I'm not sure I'm not sure
that you could get a movie with him as
the central figure out of that but
that's totally viable for a supporting
player in in an ensemble great at comedy
anyways yeah yeah he'll fit in with that
team so um I didn't like that he passed
his mantle on to Valkyrie I would have
liked to have seen more of her
like why isn't she teaming up more I
yeah I'm I'm gonna presume that was a
scheduling issue yeah but it was it was
still nice to see her back what do you
think of uh Steve picking up Mjolnir oh
that was great yeah a lot like I saw the
I saw the hammer get picked up and I'm
like did Thor some of them I was Thor's
hands not out of like oh yes I figured I
would like a couple seconds before we
saw who picked it up a like yes yeah I
would have liked Captain Marvel a limb
or two but they kind of did explain that
she is sort of us she goes solo a lot
yeah well I think they did a good job of
justifying her absence for much of this
because the way that she explains it you
know and why she doesn't even touch base
with earth that much anymore earth has
an Avengers most other planets don't
yeah they need me more than you do
sorry which that honestly fair that's
totally fair and I feel like that's a
good explanation for her being gone the
middle chunk of the movie I also like
that her coming back at the end while
triumphant was also not a MacGuffin that
solved everything there was still a lot
of stuff to do with a lot of people
involved in it yeah and yeah and also
the girl power hero shot yes yes I was
like a marvel I took you how many years
to figure out that like you've got
you've got all these kick butt women
yeah yeah like phase one at least she's
like yeah but no that was that was that
was a nice hero shot cuz you had you had
Captain Marvel you know holding the
gauntlet and you had a Quay and yet
Shuri and you had the wasp and you had
and you had Valkyrie was there and yeah
oh man and you had yeah you have a lot
now it was it was good it was good it
was good
so we did
some people so we're gonna hold up we'll
get to that one we'll get to that one
should we talk about tearjerker moments
let's save that I will say that what
will will will do that as the last
character we lost and then leap into
tearjerker moment so first one that we
lost who we didn't get back was Tony why
not not not no it wasn't but that's the
first one we're gonna talk about yes
this is how my brain works so we'll just
start with Tony forget the rest
forget through it I'll cut the rest of
that I won't but Tony
so I given that his movie was the one
that started the thing it felt like in
other circumstances I think it would
have been a much more open question who
should be the one who finally ends
Thanos but I feel like having it be the
guy whose movie kicked off this entire
thing makes it much more fitting whereas
if it wasn't that it was just like well
we have all these characters who should
do it it would have been like oh crap I
don't know but that felt very
appropriate um it also felt appropriate
because he had had that time in that
life and he went you know cuz I was sure
when the movie started that he had lost
pepper and like and the fact that he had
been so lucky whereas like Clint had
lost everyone well tony was like
basically the only one who was doing
okay yeah and leave things the way they
were I mean not like he was denying
other people's pain but like he found a
way to pick up and move on
uh-huh whereas most others didn't yeah
which actually met he he had he had the
most to lose everyone else only had
something to gain because they'd already
lost everything I made that very clear
yeah it was and I kind of figured he
would be the one he was not gonna make
it through this movie you know like he's
probably the oldest of the actors in it
I'm guessing I think he is yeah yeah and
in that date they let the the white show
and his beard yeah it was I mean but I
do love that part of his decision to to
enter into this and to you know go back
in time was to get Peter back and yes
that yeah Peter always just like ties on
my heartstrings it was Tony's that's
what's hard for me I didn't cry the
hardest but I he is of the original
Avengers he is probably my favorite is
my favorite I love I love Mark Ruffalo
as Bruce Banner and as the Hulk but it's
not my favorite character whereas Robert
Downey jr. as the Iron Man and Iron Man
character is great I love Pepper Potts
like I love to do that that's like what
got me choked up in that moment was
wasn't him dying it was pepper saying
goodbye to him and actually the moment
is hard the moment that got me was
basically her giving him permission to
let go because you know a big part of
what had been driving him for this
entire franchise was the sense of if I
don't fix this no one else will and her
giving him that assurance of we're gonna
be okay you can go that oh and I do I
mean she is together of in terms of you
know spouses or loved one she's got she
I mean it's obviously gonna be hard but
I think she can do this and I think she
can raise they'll Morgan so yeah yeah
you know I mean and that's the other
thing is like
I haven't liked when it's Paltrow and a
whole lot I've always really liked her
as pepper
well she where she had amazing chemistry
with Robert Downey jr. phenomenal
together and yeah so they were they're
my like marvel couple yeah yeah it just
worked and like she just brought like a
teething
she brought teasing but like gravitas to
the role yeah and it was great
so next we can talk about the one that
is kind of the sweeter a lot and like he
didn't die by the end of the movie but
they're obviously done mm-hmm and that
Steve yeah I was not expecting that and
I was like oh this is really I always
wanted to he's always regretted not
having that time with her and it makes
sense like when he saw her in the 70s
that he was like just the look on his
face and how wistful and like I I knew
as soon as he was stepping up onto that
time machine and he was the only one
going back I'm like he's not coming back
like I called it immediately yeah but it
was nice and it was sweet and I loved
his interaction with Sam where you know
Sam seizes the wedding ring you want to
tell me about her no I don't think I
will with this smile on his face just
the way Bucky and Sam handled it yes how
they kind of approached him quietly but
new you know yeah Tom and I like that
Bucky's kind of like soft smile yeah
like I like that you can see Sam is
terrified at taking that shield I kind
of like that yeah he's he's got this I'm
excited I mean like they've set it up
for some some fun yeah and then oh god
there's Natasha oh that was the one that
killed me that the whole thing where I
was that was where I cried the most was
like I wasn't really I hadn't gone into
the movie expecting her to go like I had
hi
phase-out Captain America and probably
Ironman and like that was my expectation
because that's what most people
predicted but like yeah I wasn't
expecting Natasha and that whole scene
where they're just struggling like I'm
gonna go no I'm gonna go and I'm gonna
go and then when you know he's hanging
there and she's just like you gotta let
go yeah and I I mean I kind of like
really the soulstone seems really hurt
like Gamora really kicked me in the
first movie it makes sense that she came
back but they had to trade someone else
yeah what an awesome father also she
came back for you know from time travel
they couldn't undo what happened that
this all stone still needed someone
within the yeah realm of the two movies
and I actually think that's an
interesting contrast because I think the
death of Gamora in the previous one
hurts because of your affection for her
and as much as I have affection for
Natasha what got me like going God was
was Clint and how desperately he did not
want her does because she was basically
the only thing he had left and he had to
watch her die yeah and you could see
that jeremy renner sold that pain very
well well and I think that's also the
soul stone is that whoever gives up and
again it wasn't like more where he
basically she did not have consent in
this death at oh he just chucked her but
it obviously had to hurt whoever's
giving up that person yeah and that's
like kind of the point of the solstice
yeah but you've gotta let them go you've
got it the person who gets the soul
stone has to have has it lost something
yeah very dear yeah you know so I know
that one or so we can talk to your
jurors so big well my big one came
fairly early in the movie
yeah and that was yeah and that this
this this was dad crying so yeah when
Scott after getting out of the quantum
realm and he died he has no idea what's
going on and you know he goes through
his whole desperate thing of trying to
figure out if his daughter was vanished
or not and looking like desperately
desperately finding his own name now
finally his daughter and also I don't
know if you noticed like checking both
sides of these tablets because he has to
check under his under her mother's last
name and his own last name too to be
certain and then he goes to the house
where he thinks she is and her coming to
the door and her and him like seeing the
years and the pain on her face but being
there to hold it like ah damn it okay
yeah so that was that was that was the
big one for me but there were other
there were other choked up moments when
when Peter came back and and Tony
embraced him that was a choked up moment
the time and just Peter being like you
know like almost he just get so
desperate like he he is one that can't
let go oh man no he can't kid you know
and like uh he's he's made new fee-free
Avenger oh oh I just I love Tom Hollands
I just really do he's he's just so
sweetly earnest
and like I totally sells that cuz
sometimes they would be like oh that's
obnoxious with certain on their actors
but he just Susie I think that Ernest is
Israel because one of the things they
have had to do is that he cannot go into
press things alone he always has to go
with another actor cuz they have to stop
him spoiling stuff cuz he just gets so
excited
he gets so excited talking about it that
he'll just whatever you know and like
they had they had reduced scripts
specifically for him with his few
details as possible as they could get
away with him knowing and still act the
scene because he can't keep a secret
worth a day the I thought the climax was
appropriately thrilling I was I was
wondering for a while when it when it
started to become like the time heist
you know how do we climax this movie but
that that was actually rather clever the
idea of two different d'amours from two
different times basically their Wi-Fi
intermingling that was yes I'm sorry
nebulas Wi-Fi are you getting cross yeah
what I really love about that is not
only does it make sense but it's totally
the sort of thing that you would
overlook and wouldn't think of but then
goes wrong when you start to do
something like cool I think we've got
everything and like you enact whatever
and this is like just not even big heist
but like a real-life thing you're like
cool everything's all set and then the
thing that goes wrong is something that
is obvious in hindsight but you never
thought of and that's exactly what the
nebula thing is I'm like oh that's
perfect I honestly love to that they
temporarily lose one of the stones
essentially because they made the halt
take the stairs it was a jump scare
would he burst through that door I like
was like oh god oh I also loved it
wouldn't like he's you know the
intermingles Banner and Hulk and he like
comes back and he's like yes Nash is
that feels gratuitous but his heart's
not in it I know again just love love
that actor in that role
so yeah um yeah I mean I would've yeah I
would have liked to have seen more Carol
we got sherry back down yes I did want
to mention that so we got I like that
the first three that coming through
which a coy was already quiet but I mean
she would have been handling Wakanda
this whole day yeah and he can she's not
superpower like okay we we know what
folks you wish we hadn't got rid of in
the first place
so okay he's still been around but
here's the challenge sorry back
we're sorry oh and speaking of people
that came back and were mad
oh so mad like Wanda
oh she was what I love like armor
shaking off him and she's just like what
I loved was that the fan Oh totally
tried to didn't you probably won't get
this reference but I'm gonna do it
anyway
Venice totally tried to do an M bison
moment he's like I didn't even know he
totally tried to do for me it was
Tuesday with her and she's like oh you
will know me it's like damn yeah oh yeah
yeah although it's it serves as a
reminder um we didn't get vision back
he's still dead oh yeah I mean that is
why she is mad we didn't get Loki back
permanently we obviously we got we got
Tommy Hill so but and he's he's getting
a show on Disney pus so we'll have the
character and actually we'll have vision
back to you because there's gonna be a
Scarlet Witch envision show as well
which means either at the start of that
show they rebuild vision or that which I
don't think they can give him that he
was proud by an infinity stone or it's
set what during the period they were in
hiding I don't know which is the case
it's hard to keep track
well they haven't said which is the case
I imagine because it would have been a
bit of a spoiler for this if they
clarified which was gonna be the case
yeah but when you didn't get handle back
no no
um it was it was it was a proper like
celebratory closing out of the because I
think that's that's the thing in a lot
of cases with these franchise is they
almost never have proper closure they
botch the landing
well most of them don't even have a
proper landing because they're designed
with the intention to go forever and
then eventually they stop making money
and they just like odd this will be the
last one and then the few that actually
try to go for an ending drop the ball
you know dark Dark Knight Rises drop the
ball Dark Phoenix is probably gonna suck
I would say the the one that did it best
prior to this was actually x-men Days of
Future past which even though they kept
making more movies after that felt very
much like a closure at least on the old
cast but this this blows that out of the
water easily and it it left things in a
state where there's obviously got to be
more movies I want to see these more
movies but if you wanted to end here I
feel like you could do that feeling
satisfied and feeling like you had a
complete story you did and I also feel
like it was almost like here is the end
of this saga at this story we're passing
on the mantle you know like cm is the
new captain like we've established you
know we're gonna have Spidey back we're
gonna have Carol back we're gonna have
obviously T'Challa yeah look on the back
so by passing on the mantle to the new
adventures in the next phase yeah and I
mean we know a lot of the movies that
are being worked on right now you know
guardians 3 and the next spider-man
comes out later this year and there's
gonna be Black Panther 2 and and
Eternals got announced which is a cosmic
thing I'm assuming they're having
another Captain Marvel oh yeah
they are they will I don't think they've
given a date for you and there's gonna
be the Black Widow prequel but what I
will be honey Mo's not like I want it
tomorrow but like what I've got to be
keeping an eye out for is what they
announce is being the next Avengers
movie because while this doesn't feel
like the
end of them of the MCU it does feel like
the end of the Avengers franchise
specifically and I will be really
curious to see if they even if they even
try to do Avengers again or if they just
let the the franchises intermingle in a
much more casual sense and don't go for
the big team-up at least not for a while
yeah because I don't establish the
characters yeah I don't think there's
gonna be a way to top this for a long
time if if at all I would like I mean I
am I don't necessarily mean in terms of
quality I mean in terms of scope and
scale and spectacle I am curious to see
how they have some of the new characters
would interact would they do a New
Avengers like I could I don't need it
right away I'm just saying like it could
be interesting it could be I think they
need to play around in their own movies
for a while and like establish L'Amour
but then yeah well I mean I think it's
probably likely we'll just get a lot
more cross-pollination like you know how
Doctor Strange just casually showed up
in Thor Ragnarok yeah I think that kind
of thing is the sort of thing we'll see
more of going forward
okay so that having a movie specifically
built to bring everybody together
doesn't feel as necessary and you don't
miss it as much because they're popping
up in each other's things more often
mm-hmm yeah yeah like Thor now and yeah
like Thor being in guardians hopefully
fingers crossed but yeah that was that
was good yeah it was good and I'm also
really glad that I waited a week and
watched it with you thank you I was very
busy last week yeah I know you were but
good lord
yes yes Avengers end game we finally
seen it I know these people can stop
asking me when the review comes out
although I'm sure I do not doubt between
when we record this and when it goes up
on Tuesday people will keep asking yeah
but in any case have you seen it of
course you have
what do you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments and let's talk about it
there's bunch of stuff to do down there
there's links there's the page on
there's merch click on them or don't if
you don't want to you don't have to
because at the end of the day you're the
council
I'm just running the meetings sometimes
with a guest and until next time it's
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]